qu'on se le dise tout de suite
l'organisation de la police américaine
n'a rien à voir avec la police française
car il n'y a pas une police aux états
unis mais des polices qui ont d'ailleurs
largement marqué notre culture cinéma et
séries télé alors comment se
répartissent les quelques 800 mille
officiers de police des états unis le
premier échelon c'est la police locale
par exemple la new york police
department ou detroit police department
où sévit c'est dans les années 80 un
certain axel foley
enfin quand il ne semblait pas pour
beverly hills
le chef de la police locale est
généralement nommés par le maire de la
ville
vient ensuite le comté où celui qui
règne en maître est le shérif
il dirige les opérations de police dans
un territoire fait de petites villes qui
n'ont pas de police locale et ses
prérogatives englobe parfois la gestion
de la prison du coin a noté des cas plus
exceptionnels comme arnold schwazenegger
en 2012 qui dans le dernier rempart doit
s'occuper d'un dangereux cartels qui a
eu la mauvaise idée de vouloir traverser
son tir est quand même de chez elles ont
des zooms encore et on arrive à la
police d'état dont la plus connue est
peut-être celle des texas rangers ou au
père chuck norris pour l'éternité deux
branches principales ici la highway
patrol qui patrouillent sur les axes
routiers et la state police qui résout
les affaires de crimes graves dont la
liste diffèrent parfois d'un état à
l'autre
le dernier échelon enfin les agences
fédérales dont le rayon d'action s'étend
à tout le territoire américain
vous en connaissez probablement
plusieurs le fbi qui enquête sur les
crimes fédéraux la dea qui lutte contre
le trafic de drogue ou encore la ncis
qui s'intéresse aux crimes commis au
sein de l' us navy et des marines korps
et pas que le vendredi soir sur m6
la particularité fondamentale du système
de police américain c'est son étroite
imbrication avec la politique
le chef de la police locale est nommé
par le maire qui est un élu le shérif
lui fait campagne tous les quatre ans
car il est directement choisis par la
population du comté et le chef de la
police d'état est nommée par le
gouverneur qu'on élit tous les quatre
ans aux états unis